[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission au sein de sa
découvre la Réunion ensemble vous allez
paraît alors allons-nous
[Musique]
familier dans la commune de
Saint-Philippe plus exactement ici à la
forêt malong aujourd'hui sera pour
l'occasion de découvrir le sentier
botanique si je regarde bien sur le
sentier n’en a plusieurs boucles et ben
nous nous a fait cette petite boucle là
ici et nous va rogner sur le point de
départ allez le sentier botanique par là
allons-nous
tous les matins 1h30 de marche depuis le
centre de pilule littoral et puis nous
on fait tous les sentiments remontant
justement de faire de la marche de la
randonnée
puis on a la tranquillité ou entend les
oiseaux chanter franchement et puis le
cadre est idéal quoi
bonjour mesdames bonjour monsieur
comment allez-vous bonjour ça va bien
oui bien qu'est-ce que vous faites là
aujourd'hui on est venu faire une
randonnée en forêt de Marlon parce qu'on
fait un projet donc SVT arts plastiques
français la collègue de SVT en profite
pour faire une étude du coup sur les
plantes endémiques endigènes et
exotiques dans son programme de SVT et
après donc les marmaïs vont devoir créer
une réalisation en argile avec une
céramiste qui s'appelle donc Alice au
cuite et est-ce que c'est important
justement pour ce bola ah oui ben c'est
quelque part la préservation de de la
flore et de la forme de Lille les
sensibiliser à ça à travers ce projet et
la collègue de français également ben
c'est son axe de travail la préservation
de l'environnement de la biodiversité
et là on fait une petite pause près de
la stèle c'est un monsieur important là
tu es revient cadet le botaniste qui a
travaillé sur la faune et la fleur de la
Réunion exactement
en tout cas elle est super intéressante
bravo
[Musique]
comme si la nature déconner à la la
paradis pour nous rester
alors du coup toi tu rappelles la
démarre le circuit rouge et là elle
arrive à l'intersection ça va sur le
bleu ah ben monsieur arrive bonjour
monsieur bonjour Comment allez bon elle
est là on est bien
une petite connerie de contrôle sur le
sentier botanique d'accord et quand
demain ou bien ces bonnes contre le
parti contrôle
les petits panneaux d'information on est
toujours en place s'il n'y a pas de
danger nous on va dire pour les usagers
et contrôler aussi le niveau de
l'invasion au niveau des espèces
exotiques envahissante et que ça comme
espèce ou bien diamant ici
principalement au niveau de la réserve
et en périphérie c'est surtout ou tabac
il y a un papillon goyavier et jamarose
Eco ça et en Costa Sur bonnes espèces là
les les pas bon de la forêt là à partir
lui recouvre entièrement le sol et lui
empêche la régénération naturelle des
espèces endémiques de la forêt Malonga
c'est développer son son particulier
de forêt primaire de la Réunion quad
dans la forêt prix mais alors que ça
avait déjà un peu ça c'est la forêt
originelle sur l'île avant que l'homme
arrive d'accord alors tout le monde
pipi de boire est-ce que nous connais
quel pays de Galles arrivent en premier
bien compliqué bah en général sur les
coulées de volcan le premier vrai arbre
qui s'installe arboricier bien sûr il
parle c'est le bois de rampant c'est bon
en tout cas les Gaïa ben moi mais ça
continue c'est le petit circuit bleu par
là merci en tout cas la trouver allez
bye bonne journée
alors du coup ça y est nous les sur
l'exploitation de vanille et il tombe
bien il en a lui là lui comment il est
allez comment
les verres dans la vanille ils sont ils
sont en nature c'est quoi un peu le bon
état pour avoir un vanille arrive à
maturation donc les gens là c'est des
gosses que nous nana ici il est venue
voilà
ça c'est des goût ce qu'elle a été
fécondé
la fin d'année disons ne peut dire que
on a la fécondation à la récolte c'est 9
10 11 mois a essayé de travailler
pendant longtemps pour faire en sorte
que la vanille de la Réunion
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]